una noche de fútbol que terminó en
tragedia gimnasia y esgrima recibía Boca
Juniors uno de los clubes de fútbol más
populares del país por la fecha 23 del
torneo profesional argentino pero el
partido duró menos de 9 minutos los
gases lacrimógenos producto de los
choques entre fanáticos y la policía
provocaron su cancelación y su
reanudación que es incierta
la afa repudia enérgicamente los hechos
de público conocimiento acontecidos hoy
en las inmediaciones del estadio de
gimnasia y esgrima y expresa su
compromiso de continuar trabajando para
erradicar esta clase de episodios que
empañan la fiesta del fútbol Durante los
hechos que están siendo investigados una
persona Murió como consecuencia de un
ataque cardiorespiratorio Aunque sus
familiares responsabilizan a las fuerzas
policiales del deceso
de la represión policial a mi hermano Lo
agredió a la gente a los 25.000 personas
que están en la cancha le dio la policía
la provincia de Buenos Aires en un
comunicado el gobierno de la provincia
de Buenos Aires informó que el jefe del
operativo fue separado de su cargo
mientras la justicia investiga si las
condiciones de ingreso al estadio
pudieron estar alteradas por una
sobreventa de entradas Es evidente que
el operativo realizado no fue capaz de
brindar seguridad a quienes asistieron
el gobierno provincial señaló que los
heridos fueron dados de alta y 47
personas detenidas fueron liberadas
cuando un optó por no avalar las
aprensiones de la policía por años
Argentina ha sido uno de los países más
afectados por la violencia en el fútbol
principalmente por el fenómeno de las
Barras bravas en la actualidad para
disminuir el flagelo los hechos
violentos en el fútbol son castigados
con prisión de uno a tres años